Cappuccetto Rosso sarà lei la mia
merenda anche a voi Hanno fatto degli
scherzi sparito qualcosa è fatto sì il
lupo ver oggi campeggio di
Halloween Challenge Io sono la strega e
io sono il vampiro e questa è la nostra
tenda da campeggio di
oggi Io sono brom brom il
pagliaccio e io sono mercoledì Adams e
questa è la nostra
tenda Io sono Katy La gatta nera e io
sono Frankie il lupo mannaro e questo è
il nostro Castello mio ed è così grande
che ci entra solo
[Musica]
Ketti
Ah buongiorno qua nella tenda di me
strega preparo la colazione nel mio
calderone
[Musica]
m Ehi ciao sono l'emoji di Anita e è un
gioco per te Prova a lasciare mi piace
entro 5 secondi 5 4 3 2 1 tempo scaduto
ci sei
riuscita proprio quello che ci vuole la
mattina questa luce questa luce mi sta
facendo diventare cieco Capisco che per
voi mattina ma io sono un vampiro e a
quest'ora i vampiri vanno a dormire
quindi
buonanotte nella mia Morning Routine
devo sempre truccarmi da pagliaccio e
farmi il naso ma in realtà io il naso ce
l'ho
già che bella giornata per fare tanti
[Risate]
scherzi mi dispiace tarantola l'allegria
di questo Pagliaccio ti ha fatta
svegliare io non lo sopporto più vado a
farlo stare zitto
zitto Non ti preoccupare Tu rimani
qui senti pagliaccio vuoi stare zitto Ma
è una così bella giornata possiamo fare
tanti scherzi ti Vale fare degli scherzi
con me
no Che bello vederti così contenta Ma
perché sei così giù ho capito cosa ti ci
vuole una bella risata Allora il mio
trucco magico è rubarti il nasino ti ho
rubato il nasino ma prima o poi riuscirò
a farti ridere per ora ti rido il nasino
pagliaccio ce l'ho io qualcosa di
divertente doore mi caduto anche il
naso
esilarante Adesso mi preparo per dormire
Sono troppo stanca Sono un gatto nero
non posso rimanere fuori il mio pelo si
rovinerebbe e E se piovesse non lo
potrei
sopportare Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita
sono qua per ricordarvi che è appena
uscito oggi il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto
sego con cui condivideremo tanti
messaggi assieme prendetelo
[Applauso]
subito Oh non ho più voce ho rullato per
tutta la notte adesso mi ritrovo qui mi
fai un posticino per dormire
Assolutamente no E quindi non puoi farmi
un posticino per dormire al riparo dai
anch'io il pelo siamo simili non mi
interessa il mio pelo è ben curato il
tuo no insomma Ma guarda quelle unghie
che cos'hanno di brutto le mie unghie
sono bellissime E va bene mi tocca anche
oggi dormire
[Musica]
qui eh sì sono pronto sono pronto C Ma
quanta luce c'è ma ho sbagliato mi sono
svegliato troppo presto Pensavo di non
aver sentito la sveglia invece ancora
pomeriggio Finalmente è l'ora della
merenda Quindi adesso prendo il mio
bicchiere di sangue e me lo bevo
tutto troppo buono e adesso posso
ritornare a dormire Buonanotte Anzi
buongiorno
eh Che schifo Vitale vampiro beve il
sangue molto meglio la mia zuppa dentro
gli schifosi E a proposito di Halloween
e ora disponibile il mio nuovo libro La
città stregata gli investigatori del
mistero Ed è proprio a tema Halloween è
perfetto da leggere per Halloween perché
è un po' paur e c'è anche un lupo
mannaro e una trasformazione Se non ce
l'avete ancora cliccate nel link in
descrizione per prenderlo subito oppure
lo trovate in tutte le librerie e questo
è un messaggio segreto per voi che
potete tradurre con l'alfabeto segreto
che trovate dentro al libro prendetelo
subito è il momento della merenda e io
ho tantissime caramelle colorate tu
mercoledì cos'hai per merenda lacrime e
tristezza sono sicuro che prima o poi
riuscirò a farti ridere Guarda questo
pettin gigante è il momento di uno dei
miei scherzi rimane incastrato non ti fa
[Risate]
ridere anche il naso mi è caduto l'ho
fatta ridere giubilo e
allegria Ti ho fatta ridere di la
verità No non è vero non mi hai fatta
ridere e non ci riuscirai mai invece sì
hai riso ti ho visto e ti hanno visto
anche loro Ehi se credete che l'abbia
fatta ridere mettete like
Ed ecco la mia merenda un po' di
latte Uffa però Io non ho niente da
mangiare per merenda andrò a rubarla
agli
[Musica]
altri
Oh Ci son tante merende Questa è la
pozione della
strega ma sono insetti e questa me la
puoi chiamare merenda Questo è il sangue
del vampiro Eh c'è pure un'unghia
dentro Ma questa è Cappuccetto Rosso
sarà lei la mia
merenda Ehi ehi Ma che cosa stai facendo
Ma quale Cappuccetto Rosso non mi vedi
che io sono il bambino Vitale lasciami
dormire vai via di qua S fammi dormire
in pace
guarda ah
Ok ok me ne
vado Dato che quello era Vitale vampiro
ho un bello scherzetto per
lui è l'ora di mangiare qualche
caramella Ah quanto mi piacciono le
caramelle
adesso me ne mangio tantissime
altre ma sono vermi mercoledì cosa vuoi
Sei stata tu a mettermi questi vermi qua
per farmi uno scherzo di Halloween No
non sono stata io invece sì Dov'è il mio
secchiello dormiva la mia tarantola lì
dentro era lì non lo
so sei stato tu no Dimmi dove hai messo
la mia tand non l'ho spostata io tu mi
hai messo i vermi non son stata io Sì sì
E allora chi è stata a togliermi la
tarantola non lo so ma non io mi hai
rubato il
[Musica]
naso È così che si fa un vero scherzo di
Halloween
Brava ok cosa abbiamo collezionato oggi
la scopa della strega il sangue del
vampiro e la tarantola di mercoledì eh
Sono aracnofobico bel bottino oggi però
sono riuscito a ingannarli tutti sono
proprio
[Musica]
bravo Ah finalmente sono calate le
tenebre Questo è il mio momento
preferito della giornata Ho già tutto
pronto per la mia night
[Musica]
routine
buonanotte Ma marcol tu non dormi no
pagliaccio A me non piace dormire Questo
è il momento perfetto per leggere questo
libro La città stregata Ah ci sono cose
paurose le mie preferite Anch'io lo
vorrei leggere Oh ma adesso sono troppo
stanco per leggerlo Ci penserò domani
Buonanotte
finalmente sveglio tenebre sonaro pronto
Adesso bevo il mio bel bicchiere di
sangue e aglio chi è che mi ha fatto
questo scherzo mi ha messo l'aglio Che
schifo È il momento di uscire fuori
andiamo scappiamo non ce la posso fare
più con questo taglio via Ah finalmente
la notte è il momento di andare in giro
con la scopa Posso volare sui tetti
finalmente Dov'è la mia scopa qualcuno
l'ha rubata non è possibile
Dov'è Finalmente la notte ora posso
uscire con i miei occhi da gatta ci vedo
benissimo
miao
Ehi pagliaccio
mercoledì Che cosa c'è anche a voi Hanno
fatto degli scherzi sparito qualcosa è
fatto sì a me hanno sostituito le
caramelle con dei vermi e a me hanno
rubato la mia
tarantolino rubato la scopa e a lui
hanno sostituito il sangue con
dell'aglio dell'aglio ti rendi conto ad
un vampiro dare dell'aglio che vergogna
eh È fatto Beh a me Effettivamente hanno
rubato il
latte ma chi è l'unica persona che manca
qua Adesso vediamo c'è il gatto il
l'elefante il pagliaccio manca solo il
lupo I due leocorni e i due leocorni ci
fno Ma che stai dicendo gatto vampiro
strega pagliaccio mercoledì manca solo
il
lupo è vero manca lupo io avevo
sbagliato storia stavo pensando al gatto
al Topolo elefante per presto trovi
abbiamo un modo per intrappolare il lupo
Andiamo Oh che belli questi oggetti sono
riuscita a fregare tutti ho proprio
collezionato un bel
bottino come funziona
questa fregato Proprio tutti ma come
funziona
questa ma si è spento la luce Beh volevi
la tenda adesso ce l'hai Ah così impari
a rubare le cose e fare gli scherzi
perché questo incantesimo
[Musica]
adesso scopriamo Eccolo qua
Il è quello che ti meriti così
impari finalmente nuovamente la mia
tarantola le mie caramelle sono tornate
normale impari a darvi dell'aglio sì e
la Challenge si conclude qua E noi vi
salutiamo e buon Halloween
Ciao